Hales gum breasts fall apart so I'm
going to take you bros with me to Japan
I'm going there to check out the square
Enix office and I'm gonna meet some
people behind Final Fantasy they're
launching a new game for mobile and I'm
very excited to go there and just see
everything behind the scenes is very
cool your brothers are coming with me
so let's go if you're Cheung Kong wish
you and stuff please don't go chef food
ready throw I'm so motion saying I want
to throw up taxi driver same to you not
a good start from the plane
we're flying to Seoul first and then
we're gonna fly to Tokyo
I'm so tired I just want to sleep we
have another flight to Narita in two
hours I'm just so excited asleep we're
in Tokyo Oh actually Narita we have to
take a train I'm sorry I hate to sleep
we buy train tickets I think I've bought
too many
I just have to find a hotel it should be
closed
so pretty
amazing I don't worry the whole entrance
is so pretty
so we're at to tell um it's kind of
amazing
there's me hey and then you come in and
it has two floors oh my god
is it cool up there Matt Sam
click must yet died this is like one of
a towel room and then we have downstairs
like what the hell that's amazing
good morning Bros we're welcome to Tokyo
today is going to be a fun day I'm going
to square enix
and I'm a little nervous because I don't
really know what I'm doing as opposed to
interview some people from Final Fantasy
and um I'm exhausted just walking these
stairs down but yeah you piss coming
along it should be really cool I'm also
very excited so let's go yeah I think
you might be oh really
what don't you're in the game are they
most excited about the number one point
is that soul project Explorer must be
yet even like the newest Final Fantasy
games which are always 3d int render yet
they being transformed into pixel art
person so that's hot as the main yellow
yeah for people who love this style
it's absolutely it's that their favorite
son yeah okay which one ski oh I'm
Swedish so they can maybe make me Viking
style me good I'm lucky but yeah oh he
says your make one character freighter
thank you are they [ __ ] fine
Julie Nelson get you'll do all right so
what do they think fans will love most
about the name yeah mommy hope you are
all good talk about song how'd it go so
now no look we living with all the
glorious past thousand characters from
previous fantasy series that they have
an emotional attachment it yeah and you
could still get that by putting up your
console yeah and this is I'm the front
of the TV or fifty or hundred hours here
but a lot of people don't have that time
anymore so the hacker this is done on a
smartphone it is great for that purpose
also my best friend is crazy but he
always talks about you always talk about
it in a very nostalgic way and it's
called at this game place upon man I
wanted to know if they sound like I'm
the same way goodbye Lance they were
different we might watch eventually in
Japan they focused on the spread out
from like the 90s yeah so this had the
effect of just drawing people in who are
like in a series like really like have
it affect on my baby here music it's
like well my music yeah
so we just got back from Square Enix
look how much stuff I got
I feel so spoiled there were so nice and
it was really fun enjoyed it way I'm
excited for the game to come out now
we're going to go to Shibuya we're
really tired but we feel like if we if
we crash then we're not going to move
Sweden free all right my weeaboo senses
are tingling
beautiful
oh my god we're walking
into the basement I don't know what yeah
to kill me I already almost died once oh
my god what is this
whoa I have everything that was a great
day I really enjoyed it
do you have fun I said D did you have
fun anyway such a great time here in
Japan in Tokyo hi
sorry it got up a little abruptly I'm
back home now spoilers I get sick if you
want to watch part two of this vlog
check out the link in description or use
the the pewdiepie app and you can watch
barely speaking of an app you should
download check out record keeper it's
really cool that I got to do this
awesome experience to go to Japan and
meet all this cool people it's real
thanks to to you bro
so thank you I really like the game I
think it's cool even for someone like me
who hasn't played that much Final
Fantasy I can now if there's a
discussion about film fancy I'll know
the characters and I know all the places
in the awesome soundtrack so it's not
only good for people who are mark or
fine it depends oh the link to the
description check it out let me know
what do you think about it that's all
for me for now
thank you for watching leave a like if
you want more from us